واشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا
عبده ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على
نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اما
بعد يقول الحافظ النووي رحمه الله تعالى
في كتابه رياض الصالحين باب فضل يوم
الجمعه ووجوبها
والاغتسال لها والتطيب والت والتبكير
اليها والدعاء يوم الجمعه والصلاه على
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم فيه وبيان ساعه
الاجابه واستحباب اكثار ذكر الله بعد
الجمعه
ان رياض الصالحين الحافظ النووي رحمه
جمعه
[Silence]
الجمعه
والتطيب
‏perkone
obviously this is for not for females
and com to asly as possible
and
supplication and on the day of
making as much upon the
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
جمعه
anyম
‏anyenderqual
say and the merit
and
that isable
encouragى
as
جمعه
الصلاه قال تعالى فاذا قضيت الصلاه
فانتشروا في الارض وابتغوا من فضل الله
واذكروا الله كثيرا لعلكم تفلحون
سبحانه وتعالى
10 سوره الجم
الجمعه
الله
much
so hereانه
وى mention الذكر
بعد الصلاه
الدعاء
محله في الصلاه
والذكر محله بعد الصلاه هذا هو الاصل
‏con andatusion
of
pray this is
now what
person
when stand fa
all of
and
الله اكبر
الله سبحانه وتالى
type of personن
الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم صحيح مسلملاه
فان الله تعالى ينصب وجهه
الى وجه عبده ولا ينصرف
حتى ينصرف العبد
الله سبحانه وتعالى
face
اللهم
‏Now this is
conction
areران
الله سبحانه وىصلاه
and
after
that conction broken
now and
صلى الله عليه وسلمعاء
السلام
يقول وعن ابي هريره رضي الله عنه
قال قال رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم خير
يوم طلعت عليه الشمس يوم الجمعه فيه خلق
ادم وفيه ادخل الجنه وفيه اخرج منها
رواه مسلم
ابي هريره رضي الله عنه
الله صلى الله عليه
الجمعه
اللهم
جمعهم
wasم
‏person might how is thatous the day was
out of parad was not necessar virtuous
for him and was not for him was a good
for us because life is a gift and
giving any of us life and not just any
life but life as a human being
life on this earth
سبحانه وتعالى
ادم عليه السلام
جمعه وعنه اي عن ابي هريره قال قال رسول
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
قال رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم من توضا
فاحسن الوضوء ثم اتى الجمعه فاستمع وانصت
غفر له ما بينه وبين الجمعه وزياده ثلاثه
ايام ومن مس الحصى فقد لغى رواه مسلم
ابي هريره
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
وضوعه
[Silence]
جمعه وزياده ثلاثه ايام
10 daysou
this broken
‏So silence in the Arabic language or in
the English language even
linguistically what does silence mean
silence mean that a person doesn't speak
but if a person
uses hand signals that's considered to
be silence
linguistically
but in the legislation of Islam
silence is a broader meaning
‏ines any commic
any
any any commic
anying
fingct
and so in prop
time
was not
‏FL
people as people
would you know may theiringer around the
dirt may draw something may move the
pebbles around fidget right that
fidgeting breaks a person's silence have
they broken their silence linguistically
‏No, but theyve broken their silence
legislatively.
‏So silence
according to the propet defition is that
silence is anything
sayct
from
so when he says whoever comes to the
makes perfect
and then comes to the and listens and
silent
noce the words listen
[Silence]
‏for
to extra days and fidgets this person
has broken his silence fidgeting drawing
‏on the carpet
tting playing with theone checking
your apps checking any of these things
will break a person's silence
legislatively so if a person does that
they will then be given the great reward
of having all of their sins for between
the two with addition of three days نسال
الله سبحانه وتالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده ان
يغفر لنا خطايانا وان يوفقنا
للاجر الجزيل في هذا اليوم المبارك نساله
تعالى ان يجعلنا من الذاكرين له كثيرا ومن
المصلين كثيرا على نبيه والله اعلم صلى
الله وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب